[MUSIC PLAYING]
REMI TAYLOR: Hey, guys.
You ready?
Let's have some fun.
All right.
I know we're at the end
of the second day of Next.
Some of you all look
kind of exhausted.
I can see it.
But just chill, have some fun.
We're going to be
doing some Ruby today.
So that's got to be
fun, right you guys?
So welcome.
Thank you for coming
to our Ruby talk.
This is Google Cloud
Platform Loves Ruby.
Because we do.
And hopefully after this hour,
that will become quite clear.
So before we get
started, I just want
to get a sense of you guys.
Who here is a Ruby developer?
Can I just get really quick--
all right, awesome.
That's what I was hoping.
How about who here has used Ruby
with Google Cloud, on cloud?
OK, sweet.
Hopefully we'll get
you guys started.
There is our show of hands.
So hey, my name is Remi Taylor.
I'm a developer programs
engineer for Google Cloud.
And of course, I'm a Rubyist.
I've been doing
Ruby at Google for,
let's see, I'm about to be
at Google for five years,
and I've been doing Ruby
full time for almost four.
So actually, at Google we
do a whole lot of Ruby.
That's not always
obvious to people,
but we do, and we're
really passionate about it
and we love it.
So in Google Cloud
in particular,
we've found a lot of really
passionate, great Ruby
engineers.
And we brought them
together to make,
well, we're calling ourselves
the Ruby Cloud Team.
So at Google Cloud,
we're always deploying
our own Rails applications,
our own Ruby web applications
that interact with the APIs.
So whenever there's
friction or something that
could be a little bit
better, we're usually
the first to see it, and kind
of selfishly for ourselves,
we want to make that
experience awesome.
And we love to share
it with you all.
So what I want to
talk about today
is I want show you
guys how you can get up
and running with Ruby on cloud.
Looks like that will be
good for a lot of you all.
As well as how to bring
a lot of our products
into your applications to
empower them with Google Cloud
Platform services.
So if you haven't noticed
over the past few days,
GCP has a whole lot of products.
No, I didn't try and fit
them all on this screen.
I don't even know all of them.
But a lot of these provide
really useful, really powerful,
and awesome APIs.
So the question I had that
I wanted to try and answer
with you guys today
is, how easily can we
use those products from Ruby?
So let's take a
quick look and I'll
let you guys be
the judge of that.
So one of the amazing things
we've been working on,
it's one of my personal
favorite things,
is we've been putting together
a number of client libraries
for some of our great APIs.
These are hosted on GitHub.
You can find them right now
under our Google Cloud Platform
organization.
Check out a lot of things there.
You can find them under
the Google Cloud Ruby repo.
If you go to this
website, you'll
actually find we've got
amazing API references
to help you get started, a lot
of good little guides and docs.
But of course, right now, let's
just jump in and try something
ourselves.
So I just picked a product.
Let's try and say Hello
World to Cloud Storage
and see what that
experience looks like.
So as a Ruby developer,
you're probably
first going to try and find--
oh, nope.
Nope.
Let's look at storage.
So hopefully you guys have seen
the Cloud Console now a bunch
of times throughout the day.
And in Cloud Storage
in the Cloud Console,
we've got this file browser.
And you can find any
of your files listed
under Buckets, which is how
we organize our files there.
Right now, I made bucket
called my-cat-pictures,
and sadly, it's empty.
So what we'll do for this
Hello World is we'll fix that.
So now, as Ruby developers,
usually the first thing
we want to do is install
some kind of a gem.
So we're going to use
Google Cloud Storage.
We'll install the Google
Cloud Storage gem.
When we open up our
fresh new Ruby file
and we're ready to go, what
we're going to require,
then, is Google Cloud Storage.
First thing we want is some
kind of a service object, right?
We want something that we
can use to call storage.
And so that, again, we
just kind of instantiate
an instance of Google Cloud
Storage to talk to it.
Hopefully, you're
seeing a pattern here.
When we want to upload to
this particular bucket,
we do a similar thing.
So we need a reference to this
Google Cloud Storage bucket,
so we just asked
storage, hey, can we
get the my-cat-pictures bucket?
And at that point,
you're already
ready to add a new
file to storage.
Really easy.
On top of that bucket,
we'll just add a new file.
And assuming you have a local
file called images/my-cat.ping,
that's all you need to do.
Although, personally, I'm
Rails developer and though
the word new_file can be a
little bit confusing to me.
I'm used to a new meaning
instantiating a new object.
It's not clear to
me whether or not
this really creates the
file on Cloud Storage.
So personally, I'm going to
roll with the create_file alias
for this.
Although, I've got
a web application
where we upload a
lot of these users,
a lot of these users'
uploads, so if you want to,
maybe I like the semantics
of upload_file better.
If there are Rubyists
in the audience,
there's one thing we can never
agree on is how to name things.
So in typical Ruby fashion,
because Rubyists developed
these libraries,
we alias a bunch
of things where appropriate.
So we'll see a bunch
of fun little Rubyisms,
because that's kind
of how we roll,
as we go through
these libraries.
But most importantly, any
one of these lines of code
does the same thing.
What it gives us is, if we
plop back into the console,
we'll see we've got
our my-cat image.
And that's the most
important thing.
So of course, this
is just one of lots
of libraries for interacting
with lots of great products.
If you follow this website and
you install Google Cloud, what
you'll get is a ton
of these libraries
for a bunch of
different products
so that you can go ahead,
open up IRB or something,
start requiring
Google Cloud Storage,
Google Cloud Data
Store, et cetera.
But really, this is just
a big umbrella package.
If you go to Google Cloud on
Ruby gems, you'll see, really,
this just has a ton of
different dependencies on a lot
of our other libraries.
So that's great, especially
when you want to try things out.
But really, in your
own applications,
you don't want to
download all of that.
So you can pick and choose.
So in your gem file
for your Rails app,
or whatever it may be,
just to add Google Cloud
Storage, or Google
Cloud Pub/Sub,
and whatever you
may want to use.
So when you get back home,
when you get back to your hotel
tonight, because hopefully
this will be really exciting,
you'll want to try it out, and
you want to try and remember
all the things we're talking
about today, like remember how
did she say I can get
back up and running,
the one thing I want you
guys to leave here with today
is to remember to pull
up our documentation.
Our docs, in my opinion,
for our cloud products
are pretty awesome.
And in particular, for
getting up and running
with these client
libraries, there's
a wonderful Client
Libraries page.
It may be hard to see
up here on the slide,
but it has enough to
get you up and running.
It has everything you need if
you forget everything else.
So if you find the
Client Libraries page,
it's going to be impossible
to see everything up here just
on this slide, but it
only has a couple things.
It has the gem that you need
to install for that product.
It has the command you need
to run on your local computer
to authenticate so that you'll
be able to talk to that API.
And it also has a link out to
the Google Cloud SDK, which
you'll use for authentication.
And we'll touch on that later.
Third, there's a code snippet.
You should be able to
just copy and paste this
into one of your Ruby
files, into IRB, replace
a placeholder, and
it'll let you prove
that you're up and ready to go.
It kind of got cut off on
the bottom of the slide here,
but actually, I'm only
missing about a line.
I could almost fit it.
These are really, really,
really teeny, simple snippets.
And finally, under
all that, it's
got a link for
everything you'll need.
And it's got a link to
the API documentation
reference for this.
Finally, worth pointing out, I
know I'm spending a lot of time
on this slide, but
if you didn't notice,
I've got Ruby highlighted.
But next to it is also Python,
PHP, Node.js, Java, Go, C#.
Now, I want you guys to all
use Ruby, because it's awesome
and we've been putting
a lot of work into this.
But if you want to do
the same thing with any
of these other languages,
the exact same information
is there.
What you need to download
in terms of a package,
how to authenticate, et cetera.
And I know for a lot of
shops the reality is maybe
you have a Rails
backend, but you're doing
some Node.js on the front end.
And it's really powerful to be
able to use a similar client
library to talk
to either of them.
OK, so real quick,
just give you a sense
of what these libraries
are like, I want to you
just a couple more samples.
You can kind of get the
look and feel of these.
So we're going to
talk to a Datastore.
Datastore is one of
Google's NoSQL databases.
And to get started, of
course, like before, we're
going to require a
Google Cloud Datastore.
We need a Datastore Service.
We'll instantiate that up.
And then we want to
insert kind of a row.
In Datastore,
those are entities.
So I'm going to make a dog.
And then kind of a typical
Ruby idiom that you'd see,
when I make that, I want to set
a bunch of properties on it.
So for my dog, I'll set a
name and I'll set a breed.
In this case my dog's breed
is Goofball, because he
is a bit of a goofball.
And then I just need to
add that to Datastore.
Easy, right?
And kind of idiomatic.
So we're using blocks.
Again, we use these products
and we use the libraries
all the time.
So as Rubyists, when
something doesn't feel right,
we go in and kind of make it
look like we would expect it to
in any other library.
And then just
finally, I mean, when
you want to query
for these things,
this should be query syntax that
you're probably familiar with
and have seen in
some libraries that
use SQL databases, for example.
I'll query for all
dogs who are goofballs.
I'll get all the goofs.
And then I'll just loop
through them normally,
just normal Ruby.
Cloud Speech is really fun.
If you guys haven't already
looked at our machine learning
APIs, Speech, Natural
Language, Translation, Vision,
I kind of recommend you
stop what you're doing now
and look those up.
Like hopefully, watch the
rest of this presentation,
but their show's so cool.
They're really awesome.
I'm going to show you just
a couple little snippets.
But here's one of the
reasons why I love this.
So Speech, we'll
take an audio file
and it'll just return the
text from the audio file.
Very complicated.
Lots of machine learning.
Neural networks.
I don't even know.
All I know is as
a Rubyists, these
are the five lines
of code, four if you
don't include the require,
that you need to do this.
So again, require
google/cloud/speech
will get an instance of a
client library, like a service.
We tell Speech that this
is our local audio file.
In this case, we have
a local audio.raw file.
And then all we do is we
call recognize on that file.
Then if we print it out,
that gives us the transcript.
It's really, really
powerful things
going on in just
a couple of lines
of really, really simple Ruby.
Translation, it's about
the exact same thing.
Really powerful,
require, service,
we're going to translate a
bit of text from one language
to another.
How goes it, to
French, comment ca va?
Easy.
BigQuery is really cool.
Lets you query over ginormous
amounts of data really,
really quickly.
There are a bunch of blog posts
that some people have been
writing about, even processing
the entirety of the GitHub
public data set.
And people have been
using BigQuery to do
really interesting things.
You should definitely
Google for this
if you haven't, like
processing every Ruby gem
file in every public
repository on GitHub.
And even parsing it to see what
libraries people are using.
Supercool.
One of my favorite things
that we made for our DSL
here is when we were making
BigQuery tables for ourselves,
so we have data sets
and they have tables.
When we were calling the
API and using the low level
API to make these things,
it felt a little bit wrong.
As Rubyists, we're used
to defining schemas
in SQL databases.
So for anyone who has
done Rails, specifically
like Active Record,
or someone who
has used the SQL gem
to generate schemas,
this should look really,
really, really familiar to you.
We use the idiomatic
DSL for creating schemas
that you would anywhere else.
And finally, one other
thing that I thought
was a cool idiom, just
because it's something
that we didn't think of
initially that we were going
to add, but then as we
started using the library
and talking to the service,
it made obvious sense.
So for logging, logging
is a really great API.
You can call it to
send your log data to.
Logs are associated with
particular Google Cloud
Platform resources,
like a Google App Engine
application in this instance.
But what I find interesting
is actually what we did here.
So if you're a Rubyist,
you've probably used
the Ruby standard library
logger class, right?
We use it everywhere.
Typically, if I made
a library, maybe you'd
be able to pass
in a Ruby logger.
That's just a
standard Ruby logger.
They all have the same API.
And then I would use that to
print out any of my messages.
Well, when we were
using logging,
we thought, well, really, in my
application, that's all I want.
I want a Ruby logger.
So in this, if you
call logging.logger,
what that actually
gives you back
is a Ruby logger that responds
to all the same methods
as a standard library one.
So of course, we are calling
logger.info Job started.
But all of those
different methods,
everything that a logger
supports, this does as well.
So it can just be a
drop-in replacement.
That makes it
really easy for you.
These are the types of things
I love that we've been doing.
Other products, click
through them, they're fun.
I love this DSL.
Cloud DNS, really cool that
you can manage your DNS records
from code.
But also just look at this.
I mean, just at a
quick glance, you
can probably get a sense
of what this is doing.
And of course, it
just, again, has
the simple require at the top.
It needs to make the service.
But then after that, it's just
doing a bunch of record updates
within a zone.
Great DSL.
You can see we're
adding an A record.
We're removing a TXT record.
And we're placing
some MX records.
Something that I know I
spent a lot of time in UIs,
and like my namespace, my
like DNS server's doing.
So knowing I can do it, and
do it this easily in code,
it's really, really
cool in my opinion.
Go check out the
machine learning APIs.
If you wanted to just
start playing with Vision.
I wish I could honestly give
a full presentation on Vision.
It's that fun and that exciting.
This little itsy bitsy
slide, small enough amount
of code, that I can
make the text real big.
Require vision,
instantiate up the service.
Tell it that we have
this local image file.
And then all you
do, the magic line
here is towards the
bottom, image.labels.
All you have to do as a Ruby
developer is call image.labels,
and that will give you
back a list of things
that the Vision API detected
and found in your image.
So if it's an image of a
cat, maybe cat, mammal,
the type of cat, which I don't
even know but the Vision API
does.
Television, if it sees
it in the background.
It's really, really
powerful and awesome.
So that was a lot.
Sorry for that, but
hopefully, you're
starting to see a pattern here.
My goal is to allow you
guys to go back and have
a sense of what
the experience is
like using these libraries
so that you can get up
and running really
quickly and easily.
And also, remember,
the code is open source
and it's up on GitHub.
So issues are welcome.
Feedback is welcome.
Definitely, thank
you to everyone out
there who has already
been a great contributor,
has been giving
us great feedback.
The community has been
really, really wonderful
and really receptive for
this, and we appreciate it.
And if you remember one last
thing, when you get home,
if you don't
remember any of this,
just remember go to our docs.
This one page will get you up
and running with pretty much
everything you need.
For anyone who doesn't know,
this is a musical rest note.
I use it for my water.
It's a quarter rest, for
anyone who doesn't read music.
So before I show
you this next part,
I want to just briefly
take you back in time.
I want to take you back to 2009.
Now, 2009 was a pretty
interesting year for Ruby.
Ruby version 1.9.1 was released.
Now, this is important, because
it was the first stable version
of Ruby 1.9.
And this brought us all
kinds of new things.
This gave us an entirely
new Ruby interpreter, YARV,
as opposed to the MRI that
we had been using previously.
And there's lots of things
that, if you're newer to Ruby
and you didn't experience
the 1.8 series,
you might not know
came through this.
Things like the new
hash syntax, where
you don't need to use a
hash rocket for anything.
The arrow shorthand
for generating lambdas.
Lots of cool things.
Basic object.
All these things are
really, really cool.
1.8.7 was what we had been
on for years at this time.
And it was a big enough change
that it took a lot of us years
and years and years, way past
'09, to actually fully migrate
our apps.
So it got us where we are today.
And interestingly, Rails 2.3.
Rails 2.3 was one of the most
exciting releases for me,
because it was the first
release of Rails that
was built entirely on Rack.
So before that--
it's almost hard
to imagine if you're
familiar with Rack.
Before that, Rails had
its own layers for things
like dealing with CGI, FastCGI,
and like all of the under
kind of servery bits.
So this was super, super cool.
So it also got to introduce
Rails Engines, Rails Metal.
And just for a bit
of context, things
like the Arel Engine
for Active Record,
for anyone who's familiar.
Or even the bundler
integration that
comes with Rails today, those
things weren't part of this.
Those things came way after.
Well, that's interesting.
Cool little bit of history.
But why am I interested in 2009?
What does this matter?
Well, it's actually just
interesting, really, to me
because I gave a
talk back in 2009.
And it was the first time
I gave a talk on using
Ruby with Google App Engine.
So really, it was my first
version of this talk.
It was my first talk on
Ruby on Google Cloud.
And of course, at the
time, it was using JRuby.
We didn't have Ruby running on
App Engine like we do today,
which we'll talk about more.
But we did have Java,
so I could make it work.
Now, when I was thinking
about today's talk,
I remembered this.
And I actually went
back and I dug through
and I found my old slides.
This is actually my old
title slide just remastered
a little bit.
And I found it interesting that
I did this eight years ago.
My main thought was why?
I'm talking to you
today about we're going
to look at Ruby on App Engine.
And I was wondering why, even
eight years ago, was that so
exciting for me?
I answered that in the talk
I gave a number of years ago.
So here's the answer of why.
Eight years ago, I started
playing with Ruby on App Engine
and gave talks about it
because of the magic.
So magical.
Back when I learned
about App Engine,
it seemed like crazy
black magic how it worked.
I liked to quote
something that--
I believe this code was on
the App Engine home page.
And it is, "App Engine
uses multiple web servers
to run your application
and automatically adjusts
the number of servers it's using
to handle requests reliably."
At the time, that was crazy.
That was amazing.
I mean, my personal deployment
system in '09 was basically
like a bunch of wires
taped together and managed
by Capistrano scripts, which
in fairness, is kind of cool.
I was really, really proud
of my Capistrano scripts.
But when it came to
things like scaling,
like what if all of a
sudden thousands of people
hit my app tomorrow,
or my client's app?
When I saw App Engine,
it seemed like magic.
It seemed like the perfect
thing, especially when I was
doing, like I was a consultant.
I'd make a Rails application.
I'd want to hand it off
and kind of say, hey,
you guys deal with the scaling.
That takes too much time.
I can't do that.
Versus we could hand
off an App Engine app
and say, yeah,
that'll keep running.
That's going to
vertically scale.
You'll be fine.
Yeah, if you get a million
requests because of some big PR
release or something
tomorrow, it'll be fine.
So these are things that
really, really excited me
about App Engine then.
And they still excite
me about it today.
So just for interest,
and to compare it
to today a little bit, even
though I was running on JRuby,
which I wasn't the
intended audience for App
Engine at the time, it was
actually surprisingly easy.
All you needed to
do back then was
sign up to try App
Engine for Java,
install all the SDK for
App Engine for Java,
and you needed JRuby.
For local development,
they had a tool.
It's great.
It boot up in emulated
environment of App Engine.
So you had a way that you can
run your application locally.
And for deployment, one command.
One command and it'd
take your application
and it'd put it
up on appspot.com.
Awesome.
There were a couple
of restrictions
that you had to deal with to
get all of this magic, though.
There was no file write
access, I believe at all.
Like even if you needed
to touch a temp file,
I'm pretty sure that was
basically, totally disabled,
which made running a
number of frameworks
and libraries
actually difficult,
which relied on saving
something real quick,
maybe temporarily
to the file system.
And a big one that
I remember really
being challenging
for me was there
was no relational database.
So Datastore, which is
wonderful and scales amazingly,
it's just a completely
new concept.
So to someone who is
used to building things
using relational SQL databases,
it really slowed me down
as I tried to learn
these new concepts.
And there were a number
of other limitations too.
But let's fast forward.
So Ruby today for
Google Cloud Platform,
there are actually a ton
of different options.
If you want, you can
use Compute Engine
to have full control
over your environment.
If you want to manage your
own Linux, Windows VMs,
and have complete
control, that's great
and we have that today.
If you're already
using Docker, you
may want to take a look
at Container Engine.
This is essentially Google's
hosted version of Kubernetes.
And finally, of
course, if you just
want to focus on
your application,
like I did and still do,
then you can use App Engine.
And it still has all of the
magic today that it had then.
So App Engine is awesome.
If you all didn't
hear at the keynote
this morning, App Engine
Flexible Environment, which
is what Ruby runs
on today, just GA'd
this morning, which is super,
super exciting for our team.
And in addition to
Ruby, it runs a bunch
of these other languages.
So we GA'd a bunch of languages
on Google App Engine today.
And it's great.
I love it.
So you can run a number
of the other languages
if you're using them
in your shop as well.
And of course, for
the Ruby Runtime,
the thing that's important to me
for Ruby on this new App Engine
is it still has all that magic.
It still has everything I
loved about App Engine then
and I love about it now.
I make my application
and just let it go.
And just kind of for fun,
just for a comparison,
today, with App
Engine Flex, this
is kind of how it compares.
Today, you sign up
for Google Cloud
and you download and install
the Google Cloud SDK.
So these are cloud-wide now.
And the Cloud SDK gives you all
kinds of tools and utilities
for interacting with and
managing products across Cloud.
And particularly
great is you can bring
any Ruby version you want.
So you're not locked
down to this JRuby.
We'll get to this later.
But any version of
Ruby you can run.
For local development,
whereas before we
ran a little emulator,
today, to locally develop
your Rails or Ruby web
application, just Rail Server.
Just use your local tools
as you use them today.
Totally, completely the same.
There's nothing
App Engine specific
in any of your Ruby
web applications.
Just vanilla, regular Ruby
app and we'll make it run.
Now, if you are
asking, hey, Remi,
but I know your
production environment
is going to be a little
bit different than my local
development workstation.
What if I want to
be 100% sure and I
want to run my app in the
exact same environment?
Well, because App Engine Flex
is completely based on Docker,
you can do that if you want to.
You can use our same runtime and
you can Docker run it locally.
We'll touch on that
a little bit later.
But for the most part,
just do what you're doing.
It's awesome.
And then for deploy,
the story is the same.
It's just as
magical and awesome.
One command, gcloud app deploy.
We'll take your application,
put it up on appspot.com,
or your custom domain.
The restrictions, I got to
strike through all of these.
And one thing that really
made it a little bit more
challenging for me to use
App Engine eight years ago,
the lack of a relational SQL
database, that's way different
now.
So today, we've got fully
managed SQL databases
on Cloud SQL.
And also, if you didn't hear
this, in addition to MySQL,
we now have Postgres available.
And that will show up
in the Cloud Console
to allow you to choose a
Postgres database real soon.
Just so that you know, you
guys can see how to get up
and running, I just want to
walk through what you need.
All you're going to need to
get your Ruby and Rails apps up
on App Engine--
you need a Google account.
Sign up for a Google account.
You need to sign
in to Google Cloud.
Get into the console.
Sign into Google Console.
You're going to need
to make a new project.
If you haven't seen
in all the other talks
that you've seen at Next,
most of the resources
in Google Cloud are
based around a project.
So here, whatever you
name your project,
your thing will deploy to
my-project.appspot.com.
And you need the Cloud SDK.
Hopefully, again, you've been
seeing this a lot through a lot
of your talks today.
This gives us the
GCloud tool that we're
going to be using
not only to deploy,
but also, it's the same
tool that we wanted earlier
to authenticate our libraries.
So this is really
useful to have.
You're going to want it.
Once you've got all that,
just from your applications
directory, just cd
into your Rails app,
run glcoud app deploy.
And that should do it.
As soon as you run that from
your application directory,
GCloud is going to say, oh, I
see this is a Ruby application.
I know how to deploy that.
Would you like me to continue?
And for Rails applications
and most scenarios,
just keep hitting OK and
your app will deploy.
It will ask you for a
little boot command,
so if you're doing
something custom,
if you're using
Sinatra, it needs
to know how to run your
application, where the file is.
But for the most part, just kick
off your command and it'll go.
So that's awesome
and that's exciting.
And I definitely recommend
that you all continue
to look into App Engine Flex.
But what I'm really
interested in talking to you
guys about today are
the things that we did
and the things that the
Ruby Cloud team learned
while developing this
to make this easier
for ourselves and for you guys.
Challenges we ran up
against when we were
trying to develop our own apps.
And the first thing everyone
needs to cover and deal
with is dependencies.
So of course, today,
you've probably
got all of your dependencies
listed in a gem file.
That's great.
And when you deploy, we'll
bundle install that for you
on the server.
We do bundle install it without
your development or test
dependencies, which is
pretty typical and idiomatic.
But that is something we ran
into when we were accidentally
installing development
and dependencies when
we were playing around
with our initial images.
So those kind of things
that we've really done
are now done and ready
with the runtime.
And if, for some reason,
you don't want a jump file,
and you don't want to use
bundler for your dependencies,
you actually don't need do.
This 13-line app
just uses WEBrick,
and it's one Ruby file.
And this will run properly
on App Engine Flex
without doing any
dependencies or anything.
It was actually a user
request that we got,
so thank you for your feedback.
We've got it, and it
is really, really cool.
You can GCloud app deploy
a single 13-line file
without any other information.
And this works.
When it comes to
dependencies, any Rubyists
here have probably
seen this message.
It's usually not
a good one to see.
It usually means the next
couple of hours of my life
might be dealing with local or
production development issues.
So usually, this happens
when we're trying to deploy
and our production
environment is missing
some of the negative
dependencies that
are required for gems that need
to compile native dependencies.
For the most case, we should
have this handled for you.
So our Ruby runtime installs
all of the dependencies needed
for those most common gems that
we run into this all the time
with.
Development header
for MySQL, or SQLite,
or Postgres, those
ImageMagick dependencies
that can be hard to track down.
Things like XML2, XSLT, which
you usually need for Nokogiri.
All these things, we've run
into the pain ourselves.
And so we've made sure that
they're all there and all
handled for you.
If you need to add
something custom,
hopefully you don't, but if
there's a package that you're
using that no other Ruby
developer would need,
it's your own
package, you do really
need to customize your
development environment.
You can, because this
is all based on Docker.
So if you run glcoud beta
app gen-config --custom,
this will generate
your configuration
to deploy a custom
Docker file setup.
This will plop a Docker
file into your application
directory.
And what this is, this
is the same Docker file
that we use to deploy in
the background for you.
So here you can see
it, but normally, we
would actually just make
this Docker file for you.
And it's the exact
same Docker file.
There's no difference.
The only difference here is you
can see it, you can edit it,
you can play with it.
And there shouldn't be
anything hidden about it.
Here you can see
the Docker file,
if you're familiar with Docker,
kind of inherits from this
other image on Google
Cloud registry called
google-appengine/ruby:latest.
And you could totally
find that on GitHub.
That is available in our
Ruby Docker repository
under Google Cloud Platform.
So that's where it comes from.
If you find bugs, you
want to file issues,
or anything like that, it's here
and it's totally transparent.
You can see this is based off
of Debian 8 at the moment.
And there's a lot of
useful comments throughout.
So for these
dependencies, for example,
we're keeping a list of
which aptitude packages
we install and why
for which gems,
so that we can keep track of
those things for ourselves
and know why we added libcurl
or something like that.
If you want to know more
about the Ruby runtime,
including how to generate custom
things, how to do all that,
I highly recommend you
check out the docs.
Again, I'm pitching
the docs, but our docs
for Ruby's flex runtime are
really great and have a lot.
So for example, we just talked
about extending the runtime.
You're back at your hotel.
You're back home
after the conference.
You're exhausted.
You may not remember
everything from the talk.
Again, just remember to
check out the docs here.
So you'll be able to find
the docs for extending
the runtime right there,
and other things that you'll
probably need or
want when you're
using Ruby on App Engine.
So like how do you choose a
different version of Ruby?
That's really important.
To answer that, all we use
is a Ruby version file.
So for any of you
guys who have used RVM
for managing your local
Ruby installations, which
is very, very common
these days, those programs
understand and use
the Ruby version file.
So if you're using
rbenv, for example,
and you want to lock down your
app to use Ruby 2.1.0, whatever
it may be, you can
rbenv local 2.1.0,
it will generate this file.
And then when we Google Cloud,
when we gcloud app deploy,
play we read that in.
By default, we use one of
the latest stable versions
of Ruby for you, so you
don't have to pick your own.
It should be good.
If you choose one of the
latest versions of stable Ruby
as your custom, that
should be pretty fast.
We've got Debian
packages that we've
precompiled those
as binary, so those
install pretty quickly
when the Docker
image has to build and deploy.
And if not, if you're picking
some older or different Ruby
runtime that we haven't kind
of pre-baked into the image,
that's totally fine, too.
We'll actually download and
compile that version of Ruby
for you.
And using ruby-build,
which again, is idiomatic.
All the tools that we, as
Rubyists, are used to using.
Another thing that
came up, I mean,
of course, when we
made the runtime,
wanted to make sure that
when you're app boots up,
it's got the environment
variables that you
would expect.
RAILS_ENV=production, obvious.
Some frameworks
rely on RACK_ENV,
maybe a little bit less obvious.
Sinatra 2.0, which I have not
played with yet, uses APP_ENV.
So we got feedback
there and we added
that, so that whatever framework
you're using, hopefully,
Ruby runtime will work
out of the box for you.
So those types of feedback
we love, love to get.
So again, check out the docs.
It's great.
What I want to talk about next
is once you've got everything
up and running, everything
should be smooth sailing
from here on out.
You understand how to deploy.
You can check out the
docs to customize things
and to learn everything else.
So try to figure out,
what do you do now?
So there's a couple of things
that I highly recommend
you guys do when you check out.
So first, we've been
putting together
a list of articles
and how-tos for how
to use Ruby with and on
Google Cloud Platform.
So if you go to the
cloud.google.com/ruby,
you'll find things like we've
got a quick start that just
takes like a Hello World Sinatra
app and walks through the steps
we did to just install the
SDK, gcloud app deploy it, go.
It's got everything you
need there to do it.
If you want to deploy
Rails, or if you
want to deploy
Rails with Cloud SQL
and see how to get MySQL
or Postgres Cloud SQL
kind of configured and hooked
up and get ready to go,
you'll find all that there.
So definitely check it out.
In addition, check out
these Ruby flex docs.
There's a lot there.
And not just things that
are specific to Ruby.
So for example, all these core
App Engine concepts, services,
versions, how to
do something like
do you know how to run something
like a Cron job on App Engine?
Once you really start
using App Engine,
you start to run into
all these questions.
What if I need to SSH
into the actual image
and the actual container
that's running?
Can I do that?
All those things
are explained here.
And yes you can.
So definitely dig through here.
And additionally,
the console itself.
So it's really easy to
just download the CLI,
deploy your app, see it's up and
running, and kind of walk away.
But actually, I highly
recommend go ahead
and also open it
up in the console.
So Cloud Console is really
good to click around
in because you'll
discover a lot.
And for App Engine,
for instance, you'll
be able to look at all of
your running instances, all
of your running
versions and services.
And something that's
specific to App Engine,
it's an App Engine concept, are
these services and versions.
I'd feel bad, actually, sending
you guys home understanding
how to deploy something
up onto App Engine
and not at least
understanding one
of these additional concepts
of App Engine, which
are the services and versions,
because they're unique
and they're awesome.
So when you gcloud app
deploy your application,
what we actually do is we deploy
up a new version of the app
and we wait for it
to go ahead and be
ready to accept new requests.
Traffic isn't going to it yet.
Once it's ready to serve, we'll
redirect all of that traffic
to your new instance and we'll
roll down the other version.
Cool.
Not that exciting,
but interesting.
But you don't have
to do it that way.
So one of the things
that I do all the time,
and you should know
that you can do too,
is I'll deploy a version
and I'll tell it not
to redirect all that traffic.
I can deploy my version and then
I can poke around and test it.
Maybe you want to run
some sanity checks.
Or you want to run a whole
regression suite on it
before you OK it
for the new traffic.
Additionally--
whoops, wrong button.
Additionally, rather than
sending all of the traffic
there, you could
split the traffic.
So one of the things
you might want to do
is with this new version,
start by deploying, sending
1% of the traffic there.
Watch your error logs.
Send 5% of the traffic there.
Watch your errors,
watch your logs.
You can also use this
for anything you want.
You can use it for AB testing.
Deploy five different
versions of the application
and see which one is performing
better, either with your users,
or actually with some
performance metrics.
It's really, really
powerful, and I
want you guys to understand
that they're there.
And additionally, services.
Because I didn't know
this initially, and now
I love them and use
them all the time.
When you deploy your Rails
app, or whatever it may be up,
it gets deployed as
the default service.
But actually, within one
App Engine application,
within one project, you can
deploy multiple different apps.
So if I, for example, here's
one thing I use this for.
I have a Rails backend, but
I also have a Node front end.
And maybe a couple of
other microservices.
One manages authentication.
One manages something else.
I could make five separate
App Engine applications.
I could make five
separate projects.
So one would be
at x.appspot.com.
One would be at y.
And I could deploy all those.
And that's fine, and
that has some benefits.
But if it's just little
microservices and I want to,
I can actually
deploy all of those
together under the same project.
So it can be really,
really useful.
Again, we got back to hopefully
you're good at this point.
Smooth sailing.
You know where to
find some docs.
You know where to go from here.
But what if things don't go
so well, don't go as planned?
You should also understand what
to do when there are problems.
So you deploy this thing.
It's been working great.
But now you deploy and
you're getting 500s.
Things are exploding.
What do you do?
Where do you even go to look
to see what your application is
doing, where it's breaking?
So this is where
I'm going to review
some the Google Stackdriver
tools real, real quick.
And this is interesting
because our team
has been working most
recently on trying
to make these awesome.
Because we're at
the point where now
we really want to be able to
get in and debug these tools
and debug our apps and
understand what's going on.
So if you just go ahead,
and after you deploy,
check out logging.
So after you deploy
your app, and here we'll
just say, as an example, like
maybe our application logs
something in case there's
an error condition,
and then it explodes.
Naive, but it works
for our purposes.
You'll run into this
horrible kind of evil page
that we all see as
Rails developers.
Need to find out
what went wrong.
Plop into Logging in
the Cloud Console.
And then this is hard
to see, but here I'm
doing like a full text
search to try and find
this actual log and exception.
But this was actually
the easiest way
that I could find it.
The logs print out
a whole lot of data.
So Stackdriver Logging
is really, really great,
but it'll show you everything
their application sends
to standard out.
Everything that gets sent to
standard error, everything that
gets written to the syslog.
You can also see like
the NGINX, like web logs.
And all of it in there
is really, really great,
and it's got great filtering.
You can filter it down
to a particular version
or a particular service.
But still, it can be
really hard to find things.
And even when I do find
the line for my exception
and I open it up and I try
and find my stack trace,
this is my exception message.
I know it's really hard
to see, but I open this up
and it's not immediately clear
where I can find a stack trace.
And now I'm frustrated
because my app is exploding
and users are telling me
about it relentlessly.
One of the things that
I see when I'm in here
is you have the ability to drill
down these log messages based
on severity, which
would be great,
but because by default,
Rails is just--
like this just picking up on
standard out, standard error,
syslog, there's nothing
intelligent that we can get.
We can't parse those
logs really reliably
to figure out, oh,
this is an error.
This is a debug
message or an info.
And we have a solution.
So we've been putting
together this awesome gem
called Stackdriver.
Actually, don't gem install it.
You're not going
to want to do that.
Put it in your gem file.
So in your Rails application,
put gem stackdriver, and that's
actually all you need.
Put Stackdriver in
there, redeploy it.
And then your application
will automatically
be sending logs and
sending trace information
and sending errors that
could get reported, but only
for the Stackdriver
services that you enable.
So if you want this, go ahead.
You're going to go
into Enabled APIs,
and look up all the
Stackdriver ones.
So if, for some reason, you
just want logs to get sent
or error reports to get
sent, you can do that.
So go in here.
For me, I turn all these
on because they're great.
Then once you've got that
deployed and you reproduce
your error, this time--
I was actually going to get
a screenshot of what logging
looked like, so I logged
onto the Cloud Console
to go and say, hey, this
is what logs look like now.
It's so much more beautiful.
But instead, when I logged
in the Cloud Console
after reproducing that error and
installing the Stackdriver gem,
this was staring me in the face
at the top of my Cloud Console.
We print out this
beautiful tile.
And it told me that my welcome
controller's index action just
had some runtime errors.
And I can click to go
and see what's there.
It'll send me into
Error Reporting,
and boom, there it is.
I can see a little mini
timeline of all my occurrences.
If I want to, I can
click in to the exception
to see what's there.
And again, it's going to
be really hard to see here,
but for good reason.
That's because it's
a big stack trace.
So now this is way easier
and much better information.
Similarly though, in logging
itself, the logs that get
sent to logs, now that
I have the Stackdriver
gem, all of a sudden the
severity is respected.
All of a sudden the messages
are a lot more clear.
Just runtime error.
Just kaboom, error log message.
So just having that
in there for logs
is really, really
helpful as well.
It'll be a lot easier for you
to filter just to your fatal
or your error logs,
which I do a lot.
If your application is
getting slow, open up Trace.
When you get in there,
if you've enabled it,
you'll see this wonderful
graph of all of your requests
that have been behaving badly.
So all of your requests
that are taking, ooh, 500
milliseconds or more.
We've got one almost a second.
And you can also see any that
particular URIs and drill down.
But when you kind of
hover over one of these,
you can click on it and
see what is taking so long.
So obviously, this is
a Rails application,
because you can see it's
showing the bits that
are in Active Record,
how long that's taking,
how long it's taking to
render the whole view.
The view is obviously making
some SQL calls within it,
so we can see all those
Active Record, Active Record,
Active Record calls.
And then if you want to go even
deeper, click on one of those.
I mean, it's not helpful
to see, oh, Active Record
is taking a long time.
Click on one of those,
and for each one of those,
you'll actually get to
see the exact chunk of SQL
that's getting sent
to the database
and how long that's taking.
Stackdriver Debug I really,
really wanted to show today.
This is kind of really
hot off the presses,
except not off the presses yet.
If you guys haven't checked out
Debug and seen it around Next,
check out the product, because
it's really, really powerful.
I was just hanging out
with one of our engineers
who was showing me some of
what we can do with Debug.
And it's kind of what
you would expect.
In your running Rails app,
you can set breakpoints,
trigger the breakpoint,
and then see locals.
Drill down and
put in expressions
to see exactly what
variables were in what state.
And even some really cool local
debugging, which seemed really,
really magical and
I'm excited for it.
So watch this space.
That's Stackdriver,
definitely install in your app
for when things go poorly.
You're going to want it.
I usually deploy my
applications to App Engine.
I do this all the time.
It works great,
then it blows up,
and I say, Remi, why didn't
you add Stackdriver gem?
And then I do and I redeploy.
We looked at the runtime.
Again, we'll check out the
docs and stuff for that.
Talked a little bit about
what the team is doing.
So I want to leave
you here, again,
with some of the resources that
you can use to go out there,
you get back to your hotel,
you get back to work,
to go ahead and play with
this, because please do.
First off, everything's
up on GitHub.
High Under the Google
Cloud Platform organization
on GitHub, you'll find all
kinds of awesome projects.
Submit issues.
Send us feedback.
We really want it and
we really respond to it.
And again, the people who have
been communicating with us
have been so, so great.
And it makes our experience
a lot better too,
knowing you're out there
and knowing that we
can solve your problems.
Check out the App
Engine Flex docs.
Search for those.
Pull them up.
It'll be really helpful
for those client libraries
that we looked at,
because they're so cool.
Remember to go pull up one of
these little client library
pages.
It has all of the links you
need to get up and running.
And finally, check out
cloud.google.com/ruby.
We're continually
adding new information
there, new articles,
new how-tos, new links
to code samples.
And we're really trying
to give this some love.
That's actually all I
have for you guys today.
I want to thank
you guys so much.
We do have some time.
We have almost 10 minutes, so
if anybody has some questions,
I'd love to take them.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]